hey there you are and oh my God what is
happening I've gotten mad and now I'm
getting even okay look sir I know you're
upset but you need to stay calm and
treat this like any other case I mean I
can't believe I'm gonna say this but now
is not the time to go all John Wick
who's that a friend of yours I wish but
he's not a real person he's a movie
assassin that goes nuts when someone
messes with his dog then call me John
Wicks because I'm about to go nuts it's
Wick singular and you already did go
nuts it cost us the trace remember look
I need you to focus the kidnapper texted
his demands how much does the bastard
want for my little doggie well that's
just it he doesn't want money he
requested all the files we worked for
May 2004. it's a lead he's got to be
connected to one of those cases somehow
interesting you know what else is
interesting grenades just please stop it
I'm gonna take Kevin to the park where
cheddar was kidnapped and look for Clues
I need you to stay here go through those
files and put together a list of
potential suspects can you do that okay
fine
I'll go through the files great
you realize I can't leave until you put
the grenades back right oh but you let
John Wicks have grenades it's Wick
singular
there he is what are you doing in my
house Brandon
you were mugged what
what did you say to him Captain it's
okay there's nothing to be embarrassed
about I'm not embarrassed and I wasn't
mugged three men tried to mug me but I
fought them off injuring two of them
wait so you heroically fought off three
guys and that puts you in a bad mood if
I did that I would literally write a
song about myself it would be like Jake
the hero abs of steel
why would you keep this for me and why
would you lie about going to fencing
because he couldn't go
because he's injured I wasn't injured I
was lightly stabbed I'm sorry you were
stabbed lightly stabbed
get out of the car
[Applause]
freeze Punk
Tina what did they get that done lost
and found at the storage facility they
have boxes of them they're everywhere
you wrong about hope that man has
forgotten more about being a cop than
you will ever know
in 1981 he caught the Disco Strangler
over disco man put down the yo-yo and
back away from the girl
wow the man is the real deal you need to
listen to him Thames aha who's Hames
Colin Haynes the freestyle killer he
took out an entire 4 by 100 meter relay
swim team in 1982.
Marco now you say Polo
the freestyle killer man how come all
the killers you caught had such cool
names the best name I ever brought in
was narrow shoes Sam because his shoes
were narrow and his name was Sam I get
it yeah you get it
looking for me nope just taking my gun
for a walk through the nightmares
Factory nice try to come but you and I
are gonna have a little tea party am I
invited drop the weapon
okay Slayer prepare to go to jail for
ooh long time and I'll say punk punk
punk I said it so it's your plan here
Kingston you gonna torture me you're
gonna put my beard back on and rip it
off again no I'm gonna cut off each one
of your fingers until you tell me who
the rat is I see well that's bad news
because I don't know who the rat is and
I need all my fingers if I'm gonna be
Wario you can't be Wario you can how do
you do it simple when he's approaching
you just tap them
damn it motion detector wait sir what do
you tap get up let's go Kingston what do
you tap what do you attack
split up cover the exits
please
he's not getting away he took my dog oh
my God it's happening
oh I see you have a knife but what you
need is an umbrella tell him why tell
them why
the storm gonna rain down on you punk
oh my goodness
wow
[Music]
you took a wrong Fluffy Boy
[Applause]
[Music]
he's done careful yes sir
that was the single coolest thing that
has ever happened relax Peralta that
wasn't even the coolest thing I've ever
done what have you done that's cooler it
was the 80s it was nothing I mean it
made a movie out of it but whatever what
what movie I don't remember the title uh
there was a crime on a plane I was a
passenger was that passenger 57 I
honestly don't know it had to have been
just say
the same times I don't
out of your mouth oh my God was it Rush
Hour what no you know what I'm too old
for this crap
it was Lethal Weapon sir are you
Murtaugh
I'm rich
you're gonna spend the rest of your life
in a little cement room doing nothing
and while you're in there I'm gonna go
for a swim and after that swim I might
dig another swim and you'll just be
sitting there on your metal toilet
thinking of me swim
swimming all day long when I get out of
lockup I'm gonna hunt you down and kill
you yeah
right oh man look at the captain he's
pacing slowly for him that's like a
full-on rage field freak out the only
thing worse is when he stands perfectly
still
oh no it's tuning perfectly still all
right I'm gonna go talk to him no I'm
not yep bam no I'm not gonna do it okay
I am I'm gonna go okay be careful you're
so brave thanks
hey Captain
what you thinking about mostly about how
Madeline once will destroy me because
you wanted a helicopter to play action
movie I needed a helicopter because I
was chasing a bad guy because I'm a cop
really it wasn't just to make this case
epic this case is epic you're just too
wrapped up in the politics to see it sir
we're tracking a triple murderer who
stole 21 million dollars and all you can
think about is Madeline lunch
you're right what's that now before I
came to the 99 I was rotting away behind
a desk in the public relations
department all I wanted was the chance
to do good police work again I just got
it
and I blew it thinking about that devil
toad
I'm tired of politics
let's get that punk Bledsoe this is
amazing of course we have no idea where
he is but I love where your head's at he
has no family maybe there was a
girlfriend or someone he worked with at
the coffee shop the coffee shop why
would someone who knows they have 21
million dollars coming take a minimum
wage job because he needed access to
that building because that's where the
money's hidden all right we gotta get
there quick maybe we should take the
chopper
here's that Chopper death blade
Sidewinder it's go time Roger that wet
blankets no from now on call me
velvet
Thunder
okay
all right people the suspect's name is
Ernest zamowski better known as the
Disco Strangler take a close look this
is the most dangerous man in America
five foot eight hunched over 93 pounds
with gray hair and blue gray skin if you
encounter him keep your distance all due
respect sir seems like a lot of manpower
to take down one sweet looking old man
oh he's sweet all right sweet is poison
pie yeah don't underestimate them I know
28 other people who did that and they
all have yo-yo swinging from their
throats so you were listening yeah we
were saying that all along thank you
gentlemen all right troops traveling
tubes keep your eyes open and for God's
sake
protect the neck
[Applause]
ny-p-d is that Raymond Holtz I see you
haven't changed a bit neither of you
Ernest what neither have you earnest
what neither have you
Ernest this is hard to watch you're just
as devious as ever you seduced the van
driver didn't you no I seduced the van
driver she couldn't resist my groovy
Voodoo and the yo-yo string was a
message
the yo-yo string was left and this is
embarrassing can we just take him in
yeah you're right this isn't what I'd
hoped for go ahead and cover them gently
this isn't the last you'll hear from me
Raymond I'm never gonna die sure you
won't I don't know what makes you feel
better no you're not
in the car okay